no man's sky can be played online but
ps4 owners will be happy to know that
they don't have to pay extra to
experience it I'm Tony and this is your
interstellar gamespot news update
PlayStation Plus is not required for no
man skies online functionality that said
you do have to be at least connected
online to register your discoveries in
the universal atlas that's a record of
the first players to discover new
planets and life forms and it's worth
noting that playing no man's sky online
doesn't guarantee you'll encounter other
players given the game's 18 quintillion
planets there's a miniscule chance
you'll ever see another living person
but hey it's still nice to know that non
PS plus members can still experience the
full game no man's sky comes to ps4 and
PC on August ninth developer hello games
has been publishing short video is about
the game's various mechanics so you can
head over to gamespot to check those out
for everything else about no man skype
you're ready in the right place